Почему у тебя вечно нет сил и вообще,
куда уходит ваша жизненная энергия?
Почему эта тема крайне важна и почему
надо досмотреть это видео до конца?
Потому что энергия - это самый главный
ключевой ресурс любого человека. У вас
может быть время, у вас может быть цели,
планы, но если у вас нету энергии, всё
это бесполезно.
Вы не добьётесь ничего, пока вы не
сможете или не научитесь управлять своей
энергией. Для того, чтобы эффективно
управлять своей энергией, нужно понять,
какие
существуют виды энергии у человека.
[музыка] У человека существует четыре
основных вида энергии. Первый вид
энергии - это физическая энергия. Это
базовая энергия, которая является
основой для всех остальных видов. Второе
- это эмоциональная энергия. Третье -
это ментальная энергия. Четвёртое - это
духовная энергия. Вы знаете, для того,
чтобы хорошо хорошо себя чувствовать, э,
быть воодушевлённым, проявлять
любопытство, исследовать и чего-то
добиваться, очень важное значение имеет
ваш уровень эмоциональной и духовной
энергии. Проблема в том, что, а, к
выгоранию приводит именно отсутствие
эмоциональной энергии, прежде всего, а
потом и духовной энергии. Почему сегодня
я не затрагиваю вопросы физической
энергии? Потому что это более простая
энергия. И как управлять физической
энергией практически знает каждый из
вас. Хороший сон, правильная еда,
умерные физические физическая
активность, это всё восполняет вам
физическую энергию. А вот эмоциональная
энергия, с ней всё гораздо сложнее.
Итак, первая большая причина потери
вашей эмоциональной энергии - это
неправильный образ жизни. Банально
неправильный образ жизни. Это не досып,
это недоедание, это минимально
физические нагрузки, там ещё что-то.
Помните, я говорил, что для того, чтобы
у вас эмоциональная энергия была полная,
для этого нужно заботиться о том, чтобы
физическая энергия была полная. Второе,
вторая причина - это страх, негативные
мысли, желание казаться, а не быть на
самом деле. Это вот эти страшные такие
дырки, которые высасывают из вас
энергию. Вот страх и беспокойство о
будущем, особенно сожаление о прошлом.
Вот эти все моменты, они в фоновом
режиме высасывают из вас энергии,
которые вы даже не замечаете. Просто
переживание, хроническое переживание
страха, она лишает вас огромного
количества эмоциональной энергии. Потому
что человек, который переживает страх,
стресс, негативные мысли, он не может
смеяться, он не может расслабляться, он
всё время напряжён. Третья причина - это
поведение. неправильное поведение,
когда, ну, например, когда работа
забирает всё время, когда вы всё время
посвящаете только работе, когда у вас
отсутствует баланс, баланс
разных сфер жизни, это работа, семья,
ваше хобби, ваше личное время должно
быть обязательно в течение дня. То есть
не надо посвящать всё своё время, всю
свою энергию только одной части вашей
жизни, особенно а в поведенческих
причинах я хотел бы отметить такие вещи,
как незаконченные дела и незакрытые
гешталь. То есть, если вы какие-то дела
не законченные не закончили, то они
пожирают очень много энергии.
Обязательно закрывайте, заканчивайте
дела. Законченные дела высвобождают
огромное количество энергии, которое до
этого, э, уходила на контроль. или на
переживание об этом. [музыка] Многие
молодые люди ко мне обращаются и
говорят: "Ну как же так? Э о каком
балансе может идти речь, если в молодые
годы нам нужно заработать деньги, нам
нужно создать бизнес, чего-то добиться.
Поэтому мы специально делаем перекосы и
работаем там по 14-15 часов в день". На
что я ответил бы так?
Ну, обычно отвечаю так, ребята, вопрос в
том, что вы пытаетесь компенсировать
свою неэффективность за счёт большего
вовлечения и за счёт больше затрат своей
энергии. Ведь это же можно было бы
компенсировать эффективностью. Если вы
занимаетесь работой 14-15 часов в день,
то я вам прямо скажу, что [музыка] вы
просто неэффективны. Значит, вы
неправильно выстроили свой график
работы, и вы занимаетесь неважными
делами. Дело в том, чтобы для того,
чтобы добиваться любых целей в жизни,
вам достаточно 6сти или 8ми часов
рабочего времени. Смотрите, каждый раз
обратите себе внимание на такую вещь.
Каждый раз, когда вы не укладываетесь в
8 часов рабочего времени, это говорит
только об одном, что вы неэффективны. И
вам нужно не увеличивать то время,
которое вы тратите на работу, а вам
нужно увеличивать и направлять внимание
на повышение своей эффективности.
Внедрите себе каж каждый час, каждое
утро и анализируйте, где вы
неэффективны, что вы можете
делегировать, что вы можете, а, может,
вы вам можно найти помощника, либо не
делать какие-то, э, рутинные вещи,
какие-то рутинные вещи передать. Если вы
каждый день будете заниматься мм
повышением своей эффективности, то вам
не потребуется тратить так много времени
и энергии на работу. Приведу вам пример
дровосека, например. Представим такую
ситуацию, что молодой человек человек
говорит: "Мне надо больше рубить дров,
поэтому я должен больше заниматься
рубкой деревьев". А на что я отвечаю: "А
а по по моему мнению, вам надо больше
времени тратить на то, чтобы заточить
топор? и ещё больше времени тратить на
то, чтобы находить другой способ а рубки
деревьев. Возможно, там найти бензо
бензопилу или другой метод изобрести и
так далее. Поэтому не идите на путь на
поводу у простого решения. Простое
поверхностное решение просто увеличить
количество времени и энергии, которую вы
тратите на бизнес. Более сложное, но
эффективное решение - это подумать над
своей эффективностью. Четвёртая причина
- это неправильные отношения.
Неправильные отношения с другими людьми.
Это незакрытые обязательства, это
неправильно выстроенные ожидания в
отношении других людей. Это утечка
эмоциональной энергии через встречи и
занятия, которые не приносят вашу
энергию, вам энергию, а наоборот
высасывают. Вы, наверное, сами замечали
очень много раз в жизни, когда после
какой-то встречи вы чувствовали себя как
выжатый лимон. было это с вами. Если это
было, обязательно напишите в
комментариях. Будет интересно посмотреть
и на все кейсы, которые происходили в
вашей жизни. Или, например, когда вы
занимаетесь каким-то делом, это дело вас
выматывает. Поэтому хороший лайфхак. По
пути я вам скажу, просто сделайте
дневник и пишите туда всё, чем сегодня в
течение дня занимались. И сделайте один
столбец, который гласит
энергия, эмоциональная энергия. И пишите
на каждый, напротив каждой встречи и
напротив каждого дела, которым вы
занимались. Напишите, это вам принесло
энергию или забрало энергию. Таким
образом, вы будете воочую видеть, какие
встречи и какие задачи забирают у вас
энергию. И ваша задача каждый день
сокращать количество встреч и задач,
которые забирают энергию, и увеличивать
количество встреч и задач, которые
приносят вам энергию. Пятая причина -
это страсти. Это излишнее потребление,
это игры, особенно азартные игры, это
социальные сети. То есть это, э, любая
зависимость, любая форма зависимости,
зависание в том же ТикТоке, в социальных
сетях и из-за этого прокрастинация и
нежелание что-то делать. И вообще,
социальные сети очень часто вызывают
эффект фома-, это с английского языка
fear of missing out или страх потери или
упущенной жизни. А вот эти все вещи
являются огромной причиной утечки вашей
эмоциональной энергии. И шестая причина
- это внешние причины. Так как мы не
живём в вакууме, мы живём в социуме, то
вокруг нас очень много внешних причин,
которые прямо влияют на наше
эмоциональное состояние. Это может бу
могут быть и оскорбления, хамство,
зависть окружающих, осуждение других
людей, критика, то есть все действия
незнакомых вам людей, которые вылились
на вас, это там хамса касира
какого-нибудь, может быть, продавца и
так далее. То есть вы этим управлять не
можете их поведением, но мы вы вполне
можете управлять своей реакцией на их
поведение. Поэтому, когда вы сталкиваясь
сталкиваетесь с такой реакцией, а или с
таким поведением окружающих, э,
враждебным поведение в отношении вас, не
пытайтесь исправить их. Меняйте своё
отношение или и меняйте свою реакцию к
этому поведению. Таким образом, мы
рассмотрели шесть основных причин.
Конечно же, причин гораздо больше, но
это основные причины. И даже если вы
будете обращать на эти основные причины
и применить применять те лайфхаки и
инструменты, которые я вам сегодня
озвучил, это гораздо облегчит вашу
жизнь. M.